So, as promised, we're going to learn now how to create a parent material.
And to give you a bit of an overview of how I'm going to do this, again, I'll talk you
step by step through the editor if you're unsure of the process here.
But I'm just going to walk through the steps in case you just wanted to know the TLDR version
of this.
But we want to create an opaque parent material.
So start simple and move away up.
We can add constant nodes to primary inputs.
Like we said, we can add the base color, the metallic, the roughness, and just get started
from there.
And then we'll add some parameters.
So we'll add a parameter to our material and we'll make sure that we can adjust the values
then using a material instance.
So we can add vector parameters.
We can add names to these parameters and then edit them in the instances after.
So when I create a material instance, I'll be able to check that those parameters are
exposed and I can edit them correctly.
So let's dive into the editor and let's create a material plus a material instance to really
describe exactly what we're talking about here.